we are going to start with the news and
that begins in California where a new
storm system threatens millions of
people with flooding and other damage
it's a so-called atmospheric River
you've heard it before hitting the
northern part of the state with heavy
rain and also snow it's a system that
could worsen the damage already done by
storms that drop feet of snow in some
areas and flooding from new rain and the
melting snow is what officials are
really worried about at this hour Carter
Evans has made his Way Northeast of
Sacramento awaiting well that's a
Rushing River behind them cardio good
morning
Good morning Tony and it's been raining
pretty steadily for hours right now that
means Creeks like this one all over are
swelling we're in El Dorado County it's
one of 34 counties Statewide that is now
under a state of emergency it's much
warmer today and all this rapid snow
melt well that could cause some
life-threatening flooding
the rain is already drenching Northern
California causing Creeks to swell with
high winds littering streets with debris
and knocking down trees
in Donner Lake It Was a Race Against
Time to remove several feet of snow from
rooftops if you leave all this snow here
and you get rain on top of that it's
gonna be really heavy and it could
collapse the roof it could yeah
that's exactly what happened to this RV
storage facility the roof crumpling
under the weight of the snow but most of
California is prepping for another
battle the rapid snow melt which could
create dangerous flood conditions
authorities have ordered evacuations in
Santa Cruz County which is expecting as
much as eight inches of rain but this
homeowner says he's staying put we want
to be here when the flood happens just
to
help you know to see if we can mitigate
anything First Responders are activating
Swift water rescue teams one week you
got people making snow rescues the next
week you got people prepared to hit the
boats absolutely that's the kind of the
nature of the Beast it's been the best
of times and the worst of times for
California's reservoirs last year water
in Lake Oroville north of Sacramento it
sunk to its lowest level ever but now
those levels are up so high California's
Department of Water Resources is
planning to open its main Spillway today
to keep it from possibly overflowing
there's two kinds of water emergencies
when you have too much and when you have
too little and sometimes we have to
worry about both in the same year
now this storm could bring up to five
inches of rain here in Placerville when
I am across the state several rivers are
expected to reach or exceed flood stage
and then the wet storms well they
continue into next week Gail
Carter thank you we're all feeling for
California right now they just can't get
a break